People have a hard time talking about money because money is the root of all of
our problems.
My relationship with money is I don't like understand money.
My other
sock,
my name is Quinn,
I'm 22 years old and I live in San,
I'm a software engineering intern at a small startup.
Do you mind telling me how your day started?
I woke up and then went in my car to get something and found out that it had
been towed.
And how much did that cost?
Okay,
I got a 90 something dollar discount cause that was the first time my car had
been towed.
It still came out to almost $600 or sorry today?
Yeah,
minus 600.
I'm paid $2,000 a week for a 40 hour a week.
That's $50 an hour.
Um,
so computer science is something I had just dabbled in as a requirement for my
math degree and then I just
decided to do it
and he's with me as well.
I'm Dawley Avenue.
I am 23 years old and I live in Los Angeles,
California.
I make a living using my camera to take pictures.
So like great thing about freelancing is you never really know how much you're
going to make you take your,
um,
four or five games.
So I like safe loss loss of,
I don't got to work in c plus plus a lot.
What kind of programming do you want to go into?
Problems with application.
Oh Gosh.
Good luck
keys.
Ooh,
cute.
Oh my gosh.
Wait,
getting into the office.
I probably spend about 30 minutes to an hour just figuring out what I was doing
last time I was working.
I like where I work a lot right now.
Do I love coding?
No.
It's too much of how the sausage is made.
Thank you for the tea.
Hey,
we were shooting with Brooke who wanted to make a calendar for her boyfriend.
Bubbles.
Yeah.
Nice.
It's going to be fun.
Fit Five 30 east eighth street.
I'm assuming this way.
Friends.
Sweet.
Thanks.
It's an intimate space.
No,
straight on.
More angle.
Do you want me sitting and stuff anyways?
Yeah,
be cool.
Um,
yeah,
just let me know of anything else but get eh,
my favorite thing to photograph hands down is people.
I absolutely love the energy and understanding somebody's,
I think that's what what makes me keep creating,
okay.
Take so much for someone to be completely confident and vulnerable.
So allowing me into their space and capturing their soul in a sense.
I think that's rewarding.
He's like,
great.
And if you smile smelled that way.
Okay.
Did you see one go smile.
Yeah,
it's fine.
Engineering slack this morning,
like anybody else.
Upgrade to EMX 26 is working swimmingly.
Can I grab both finished and goat cheese quiche and a macho latte.
I think that people problems are more interesting than technical problems.
So my favorite part of my day as a software developer is when I got to solve the
problem with someone else.
So I guess I could be happier if I was just teaching high school.
Pursue that.
I think it's important that you aim for things you're passionate about but that
need not be grounded in your career.
Like,
I would not want my parents to feel insecure about my future.
After my third semester of college,
my dad was diagnosed with multiple Myeloma,
which is a type of bone marrow cancer and I'm his only child.
Um,
so it fell on me to take care of him.
Luckily he came out the other side.
There was no way I could value two years in the middle of my life over two years
potentially.
My decision to take care of him was very like logical cause that's the type of
person I am.
That's the way I solve problems.
Okay.
That's okay.
Busy
like where the Kardashians and who are just having somebody,
he can hear me.
These are going to look so good.
I had a tough life because my parents were incompatible.
Emotional abuse,
physical abuse.
On top of that,
they didn't have an education.
They're trying to find a job,
trying to find a place to live and having children to take care of our
circumstances put us in situations that weren't ideal.
That's how he grew up and from there we just kind of learned how to survive.
I think like with money,
if you make the effort to change your mentality and your lifestyle,
that goes even with your career and if you're open minded to change like you can
pursue anything that you put your mind to.
That's where I'm trying to do with art.
Look back at me.
Got To Photoshop your friend out.
Okay.
Wow.
Do you believe that money defines yourself or others?
Yes.
Oh,
money is part of what turns you into who you are.
In almost every person that I've ever met,
I wish it were different.
I don't think money defines you.
I think your character defines you.
I think how you treat people to find you and also how you treat yourself defines
you.
Okay.
It's kind of ingrained in us,
right?
Money is quiet literally how much you are worth,
no matter how you try to spin it.
Like there is a number
and I'm sure to some degree we all say that it doesn't like money can't buy
happiness.
Right,
but a lack of money.
You can lose you some happiness.
Are you happy?
I think I'm happy I wake and look forward to my day.
Could I be happier?
Yes,
absolutely.
Like it's not in my nature to pinpoint what would make me happier.
Everybody wants to strive for more.
I think I'm happy in terms of I'm making art and I'm getting paid for it.
I didn't really have anything and I was happy.
So because of that,
at the end of the day,
I don't really feel like,
hmm,
what's the question?
So what's your day looking like?
You could do the math in your head.
A $400 a day.
Every day.
How much should I spend?
48 bucks plus the 600 from this morning.
[inaudible] $650 ish.
Nice to Katie,
how you feel about that day,
you know,
besides the car,
it was pretty good.
Okay.
No free.
I'm case by
how much money did you make today on that sheet?
Well,
for the most part,
the three hours,
I made 400 and she paid for the studio,
which is $80 we're still deciding moving forward with the image costs.
Oh,
it's really good.
Tiredness can
sometimes nine
can keep this from Craig.
Okay.